all right everybody i am dave rubin this
is the reuben report direct message it's
march 9th 2022
we are live streaming on rumble youtube
and blaze tv subscribe
blah blah blah there's a notification
bell okay you know the drill uh we have
a tremendous show for you today it is so
tremendous i've busted out the fake news
man glasses okay that is the level of
analysis of serious analysis we're gonna
give you people because other people
wearing fake glasses are saying things
and they're making you believe things
that aren't true and i thought the only
way we could possibly counter that is if
i could get a pair of fake glasses my
eyes are perfect 20 20 vision if i could
put on the fake glasses and respond to
the fake glasses people as they're lying
to you before we get to any of that
though this is also very important you
know there's this huge situation
happening here in florida where
literally if you say the word gay and we
covered this yesterday if you actually
even in the privacy of your own home if
you're out on the street if you say gay
we're being told that the authorities
will come and get you put a back a black
bag over your head take you to an
undisclosed location where ron desantis
tickles you or something um and i tested
it out this morning i was walking the
dog
okay just out there we like to take a
nice half hour walk in the morning it's
how i clear my mind before i get going
about 7 30 a.m walk in clyde
and i just started i just i started
whispering a little bit just walking out
okay
okay gay just saying it over and over
repeating it saying it to bushes into
trees
another dog walk by the woman had
headphones on so i knew she couldn't
hear me i said it to the dog
nothing happened
nothing happened so it seems to me
you know and i'm just i know this is
anecdotal but i'm it seems okay i think
you can still say gay in florida and uh
but i don't want to get anyone in
trouble here so don't don't take my word
for it talk to your friends and family
and uh and we shall see what happens
and anyway the show today is about biden
he's a liar it's about the
administration they're all liars gas
prices are going nuts they promised it
wouldn't they've been lying the entire
time the media's running cover for him
and all that good stuff after the show
today i finish up day three the final
day of doing the audiobook for dumper in
this country you can pre-order don't
burn this country
right now it's out on april 12th but you
can pre-order it now just go to
daverubin.com
book and i i'm telling you you're going
to dig the book you know it's funny the
way these things operate you write them
and then you basically the publishing
process is so slow that it i basically
finished writing this thing about a year
ago and then there was some editing over
the last year
but as i'm reading it again for the
audiobook i'm like this thing's funny
and it and it's pretty on point and it's
it's very relevant i think in an odd way
it's more relevant today than even when
i wrote it um and i think you will dig
it so uh please pick up a copy if you've
got a couple bucks to spare okay so
we're doing biden media the gas fiasco
and the rest of it uh but before we do
any of that i want to talk to you guys
about american home shield you know no
one likes to think about household
breakdowns but they happen and way more
often than any of us would like that's
why it pays to have a plan from american
home shield to help cover the costs to
repair and replace things like your
heating system ac or your fridge they
also know that no two homes are the same
that's why they have new options to help
you find just the right coverage
american home shield members get more
their plans help protect parts of up to
23 essential home items and appliances
no matter how old they are ahs also
offers electronics coverage available
for an unlimited number of eligible
items like smart watches flat screen tvs
and more other options include roof leak
repair i've got a roof leak right now
actually and pool and spa coverage if
american home shield can't repair the
covered item they'll replace it
we are working on a a little roof
situation at the moment
we got a little leak it does rain here
in florida that's what i found out
keep your home up and running and budget
on track with american home shield right
now reuben report listeners can take 50
off their most comprehensive plans ever
go to
ahs.com ruben now to save 50 bucks
that's
ahs.com ruben for 50 off any plan
american home shoe be sure with the
shield service fees limitations and
exclusions apply c plan for details and
now back to me actually every time biden
or anyone from the administration or on
the media says anything they should have
to end their thing like that service
fees apply we're mostly bullshitting you
you know what i'm saying okay there we
go all right
joking aside for a second although i do
have my newsman glasses here
the prices of gas in this country are
blowing up absolutely insane the highest
that i've seen so far
was a picture i saw from yesterday
somewhere in california 6.99 for regular
unleaded gas when i was in california a
couple days ago i saw gas at like 5.89
et cetera et cetera oh i mentioned
california got to throw some cash in the
uh escape cali bucket okay fine there
you go um but gas prices are exploding
and we were promised that this would not
happen because this administration was
going to do everything they could to
keep gas prices low
and
you know even though they were going to
somehow transfer us to green energy that
don't worry about that gas prices would
not be affected here's joe biden who is
the elderly man pretending to be
president here he is back in october of
2021
claiming that gas prices were going to
come down
gas prices because
gas prices relate to
a foreign policy initiative that is
about something that goes beyond the
cost of gas and we're about 330 gallon
most places that now when it's up from
was down in the single digits i mean
it's
a dollar plus
and uh and that's because of the supply
being withheld by opec and so there's a
lot of negotiation that is
there
there's a lot of middle eastern folks
want to talk to me
i'm not sure i'm going to talk to them
but the point is it's about
gas production there's things we can do
in the meantime though do you think
there's a i mean do you see a do you
have a timeline for gas prices when you
think they may start coming down
my guess is you'll start to see gas
prices come down
as we get by and going into the winter i
mean excuse me in the next year in 2022.
i don't see anything that's going to
happen in the meantime it's going to
significantly reduce gas prices
ladies and gentlemen
if you pray
if you pray to a power beyond us
a god
one god
if you're polytheistic if you pray to
many gods
now is the time to pray
because if you think that that man is in
charge
we have got a huge problem on our hands
whether he actually is in charge or if
he's not in charge we have another
problem on our hands there's a big issue
here all right so the usual mudder
muddled stammering just nonsense out of
him okay so be it
gas prices obviously have not been going
down they are exploding to the point
that even the new york times yes i'm
going to quote the new york times to
show you that i am a fair arbiter of
communicating news we've got some info
from the new york times they're even
covering the ridiculousness right now
from the times the average price of a
gallon of regular gasoline reached four
dollars for 173 on tuesday according to
aaa surpassing the previous high in july
2008 when the national average was 4 and
114
the prices are not adjusted for
inflation tuesday's average represented
an increase of about 72 cents from a
month ago including about 55 cents in
the past week that's completely bananas
president biden on tuesday announced a
ban on importing russian energy into the
united states russia is a major producer
of oil and natural gas and western
countries had been avoiding russia's
energy sector when imposing sanctions
conscious of the potential
economic pain it could bring home but mr
biden has come under increasing pressure
from congress to cut off russian oil now
you also may remember last week we
covered it where uh saki said you know
we're gonna put in the most intense
sanctions oh my god we're going to do
sanctions like nobody's ever seen before
they're going to be banana sanctions
it's crazy uh and then we found the
deputy energy secretary saying no no no
we're not going to do anything with
russian oil because you know we need
that oil um
here's uh here's joe biden saying he's
going to do everything he possibly can
so that putin can't screw us build up on
ukrainian borders just since then
the price of the gas at the pump in
america went up 75 cents
and with this action it's going to go up
further
i'm going to do everything i can to
minimize putin's price hike here at home
joe
you're going to do everything you can to
minimize putin's price hike you're not
going to believe this conor give me an
image thank you this is from cnbc
remember the keystone pipeline and it
was going to bring an awful lot of gas
from canada western canada alberta area
and they were going to bring it down
here to the united states well i'm going
to just read it right there because i
don't think joe remembers about this
thing that he canceled right when he
became president keystone pipeline
officially canceled after biden revokes
key permit and what is the keystone
pipeline i got two bullets for you
keystone xl was halted by owner tc
energy after u.s president joe biden
this year revoked a key permit needed
for a u.s stretch of 1200 mile project
and here's the key part if you're not
sure exactly what this thing is the
keystone xl pipeline was expected to
carry
833 000 barrels a day of alberta oil
sands crude to nebraska
now that's pretty interesting
because he just said
that he was going to do everything he
could but actually when he became
president he screwed us big time
interestingly we did a little research
on this too right now
right now we get 672
000 barrels a day of oil from russia
keystone would have given us 510 000
barrels a day okay do you see that so
it's basically the same number it's off
by you know what is that like 15 20
something like that so we would not be
in this situation if he had not revoked
the keystone xl pipeline which he
did
but
he says that
it's not true that what he's doing is
causing a problem look let me be clear
about two other points first
it's simply not true that my
administration or policies are holding
back domestic energy production
that's simply not true
what's going on over here can i see that
image again because he's saying it has
nothing to do with him here's a headline
from cnbc
what what what this is groundhog day
people keystone pipeline officially
canceled after biden revokes key permit
didn't we just hear that guy say it has
nothing to do with him
isn't that what what we just heard and i
just told you that keystone would have
given us 510 000 barrels a day and we
get 600 roughly from russia so it would
have kind of been a wash
lordy lordy
townhall.com had this really fantastic
video that we had to show you about all
of this this is former president donald
trump predicting that we would be in
this mess if joe biden became president
and then they juxtaposed it with
something that gay pete said take a look
we have more oil than anybody okay and
it's an incredible thing that it's
happened over the last few years a lot
of great things and you're paying what
two dollars a gallon for your gasoline
that's okay
you know what that's like that's like a
tax cut
that's bigger than a tax cut
if biden got in you'd be paying seven
dollars eight dollars nine dollars
didn't they say get rid of your car last
month we announced a 5 billion
investment to build out a nationwide
electric vehicle charging network so the
people from rural to suburban to urban
communities can all benefit from the gas
savings of driving an eevee
ah so there you go i don't want to get
banned from youtube but the orange man
was right gas was gonna get close to
seven dollars and maybe it'll get to
eight or nine if this war continues to
get ramped up and everything that we do
here is completely mismanaged by that
elderly gentleman and then of course
really what this all leads us to is that
what they really i think at this point
and i don't want to sound like a crazy
conspiracy theorist but what they're
really leading us to is they are trying
to destroy the fossil fuel industry they
are trying to get us off
all of the stuff that has created more
wealth and prosperity and brought more
people up
than could have ever possibly been
imagined right over the last hundred
years let's say
and they want us on their
green new deal and they want everyone on
electric cars and everything else now as
i said yesterday and i've said many
times i'm not inherently against
renewable energy of course but that
doesn't mean it's the best right now in
the midst of this crisis nor that the
people that are ushering it in are the
people that really have a good handle on
this even elon musk from tesla is saying
we have to unleash american energy
okay we've got some info here from the
uh wall street journal because uh what
biden is doing is just compounding the
problem over and over again let's get to
it president biden is scrambling to
contain soaring oil prices which closed
at more than 123 dollars a barrel on
monday it speaks volumes about his
administration that it's seeking help
from vladimir putin's client in
venezuela
and are estranged saudi allies rather
than u.s shell producers or canadian
friends that's right that's right come
back to me for one second yes because
now russia is bad guys we going to
venezuela because suddenly they're good
guys okay let's keep going the trump
administration in early 2019 sanctioned
venezuela's state oil company pdvsa to
squeeze nicolas maduro's brutal regime
which has impoverished the country
persecuted political opponents and sent
millions of refugees across the region
come back to me for just a sec but we're
cool with that now because they're not
russian so it's all good we'll buy your
oil okay but venezuela continues to pump
about 800 000 barrels a day
with help from russia and iran the
venezuelan has returned the favor by
supporting mr putin's war on ukraine and
denounce the west's economic war against
the russian people come back to me for a
second so you see what's happening here
we're buying or we're going to buy gas
from venezuela who are kind of in
cahoots with putin in the first place
but okay let's keep going axios also
reports that the president is
considering a personal visit to saudi
arabia to patch up relations with the
crown prince whom mr biden has made a
show of disdaining when he took office
at the same time the administration has
been seeking reproachment with iran
which backed the houthis in yemen waging
war against the kingdom and united arab
emirates so you know these are all great
people that we'll be working with you
know because putin bad i get it putin
not good you can't just invade a country
i mean all right joking aside for a
second you can't just invade another
sovereign nation you can't he's killing
all sorts of innocent people i don't
want to diminish that actually um but
this idea that we're pivoting to all the
other bad people some of whom are
funding some of the stuff in russia in
the first place
if this was a script you'd go man it's
just too obvious like it just shows
their incompetency just too well
here's fox news's peter ducey who's an
actual journalist we got to get him on
the show can we get peter ducey on the
show do we have a phone number or an
email address let's get that guy
talking to jen sake
about the keystone xl pipeline and what
happened there
there's this talk about a possible
forecast for financial pain particularly
at the gas pump
for americans the president said today
the notion that this is going to last
for a long time is highly unlikely
would he try to ensure that by lifting
some of the restrictions that he's put
in place on the energy industry or
rethinking some projects like the
keystone pipeline
well first of all the keystone pipeline
is not flowing so i'm not sure how that
would solve anything there's also plenty
of oil leases that are not being tapped
into by oil companies so you should talk
to them about that and why
but what the president's talking about
is we certainly understand and he said
this today right may have been in
response to your question i don't
remember but um if there's an invasion
of another country by a big country
there's going to be impacts on the
markets right and we certainly
anticipated that and we anticipate that
as it relates to the global oil market
as well so that's why the president for
weeks now has been engaging with a range
of big global suppliers some in the
middle east others to
see what we can do to ensure their
supply out there in the market to reduce
the impact on the american people
all right
saki you're making me do it
i'm putting on the newsman glasses to
make a point directly to you
you are a horrible horrible soulless
person i i don't understand how someone
for a living could lie about literally
everything your existential crisis must
be massive and i i know you hate
yourself we can see it we can see it on
your face we can see it um the line
there when he he's basically saying
ducey and why are they all wearing masks
i have no freaking idea ducey take off
the mask i like you dude but take the
mask off um
the line he's basically saying to her
hey why don't we do something about that
keystone xl because you know that thing
would bring a lot of gas from canada we
wouldn't be so reliant on uh on russia
or venezuela or et cetera et cetera you
get you get what's going on here lady
and she goes uh the keystone pipeline
isn't flowing
yes no [ __ ] sherlock you people shut it
off
calm down dave okay calm down uh we've
got a little bit more on the keystone
pipeline this is this is a really
interesting video that we found this is
alberta premier jason kenny now again
the keystone pipeline would originate it
originates in alberta they've got a lot
of oil in western canada huge amount of
economic activity that is being crushed
because we shut this thing down so this
is alberta premier jason kenney talking
about the fact that we shut it down and
now all of the ridiculously horrible
ramifications that it's leading to take
a look states is serious about this they
could come back to the table and help us
build keystone xl
uh you know if president biden had not
vetoed that project it would be done
later this year
840 000 barrels
of democratic energy that could have
displaced the 600 000 plus barrels of
russian conflict oil that's filled with
the blood of ukrainians
now instead president biden's white
house is talking about him going cap in
hand to saudi arabia to ask the kingdom
to increase its production while saudi
arabia is using oil money to
drop barrel bombs on yemeni civilians
he's also negotiating with uh
to end the
oil sanctions on iran
a regime that has
dropped uh bombs on civilians in
syria through the assad regime
and apparently they're also negotiating
dr lifting sanctions on venezuela
a regime that kills its political
enemies and is one of the worst human
rights violators on the face of the
earth none of this makes sense
and so i will be speaking truth to power
in the bluntest terms possible
that that if the u.s administration
uh wanted instead of going cap in hand
to the venezuelan iranian saudi and
dictatorships to replace russian
conflict oil
they could we could turn this around i
believe in less than a year
you know how i always say when someone's
speaking the truth it just becomes
obvious that guy's telling you the truth
right there he's saying we can solve
this problem right now we've got the oil
unleash the oil why isn't america
looking at an ally that's a basically a
pretty good country sure trudeau is a
douchebag but besides that the people of
canada pretty good democratic nation at
least for now but why won't they do it
because it has nothing to do because hey
the administration doesn't care about
lowering costs they they want to destroy
everything the i think that could that's
really the only assessment you can make
at this point they can't be this
unintentionally bad at everything they
do they seem to want to destroy
everything of the world we once knew in
an america that we once knew so either
they're intentionally doing it and
they're intentionally doing it because
they want to usher in this green new
deal and get everybody on electric cars
etc etc etc or or they're just
well
very or they're completely inept like
they're so inept it's extraordinary it's
hard to even imagine how how bad that
would be but good for jason kenny just
like taking it to biden we've got oil
you need oil stop buying it from bad
guys you can buy it from good guys we've
got it here we're ready to do this thing
but they won't do it they won't do it
unless public pressure becomes so
intense that they have no choice but i
would be i would be absolutely shocked
and the reason i'd be shocked is because
what they have behind them is the media
and the media does nothing better than
carry water for democrats and stupid
policies
here's a cnn which is the uh the comedy
channel uh and this uh we've got a
little compilation here celebrating a
teeny teeny tiny gas decrease price and
gas going down back in december
2021
here at home americans are finally
getting some relief finally right
good news people we talk so much about
bad news oh my gosh
this is good news gas prices are heading
south down
government forecast forecast says that
they could drop
below
three dollars
a gallon
finally some economic relief however
minor americans are paying a little less
at the pump after weeks of rising energy
prices relief for the united states as
energy costs drop that pain that you've
been feeling to the pump it may be
short-lived there is finally some relief
at the pump good news at the pump
finally getting some relief as you
mentioned the national average price of
gas dropped four cents in the last week
gas dropped nearly a nickel in the last
week it's a seven week low it's moving
in the right direction the average is
now at a seven week low actually a seven
week low slightly lower gas prices so
that's good news yeah this is the kind
of positive news we've wanted really
good economic news including dropping
gas prices gas prices will tumble below
three dollars a gallon soon so that's
good news person familiar with the white
house is thinking told me today that
lower prices of the pump are good news
and i do think we have to note that gas
prices and natural gas for example going
way down there are plenty of signs that
the us economy is strong this economy
moving in the right direction it's not
perfect there are inflation concerns
here but there are a lot of things to be
very very grateful for as we head into
the christmas season
god that's just fantastic like they're
just such fraudulent liars what they're
talking about there this is again
december of 2021 they're talking about a
four cent or nickel
decrease and oh my god this is the
greatest thing and the fake glasses
everybody's got the fake glasses so i'll
do the fake glasses for the rest of this
so just to be clear in december that was
a compilation of the clowns at cnn
celebrating the fact that your gas is
going down four cents or a nickel okay
four cents or a nickel um gas i said
this earlier but i just want to really
drive the point home gas has gone up 73
cents
this month
55
cents this week so if these people were
actual journalists
they would be on cnn today screaming
they would be going bananas because they
were so celebratory my god it's so great
it's such a great indicator of the
economy
almost a nickel people
73 cents in a month that's actually
completely insane but they really are
just carrying water
for the bad policies of the
administration here's a cnn reporter
telling us how excited we all are to pay
a little bit more right now here at home
at the pump a lot higher kate but as you
mentioned people we've spoken to over
the last couple weeks they're okay
paying higher prices if it means holding
russia accountable for what they are
doing in ukraine but these prices are
likely going to creep higher kate we'll
see how they feel in the next week or so
kate and the big question the big
unknown is do any of these moves change
putin's behavior change the way he is
acting right now
these people are fiction writers people
we've talked to are very happy about
paying more if it stops putin it'll stop
putin if we pay a little bit more we've
been talking to people i talk to people
all day long okay are you happier oh he
got a tesla good for this guy you
happier no you didn't even get a car yet
he's working on getting a car you you
got a car you're not happy not he he has
a truck he gave me a sad face people are
not happy about paying more gas and
guess what you paying 73 cents more for
your gas or what will eventually be 1.25
more a gallon or whatever else is not
going to stop putin okay it's not going
to stop putin but at least but you know
look we've got bad news people fine at
least we have these late night comedians
who help us at the end of the day you
know it's because it's stressful the gas
prices going up the supply chain
collapsing food prices going up all the
bad stuff that's happening all over the
world but thankfully we have late night
comedians great people who cross the
partisan divide and you can put on their
comedy programs at night and feel good
because they care about you
here's stephen colbert russia has been
hit with a series of crippling sanctions
and it looks like there's more to come
because the u.s and its european allies
are now discussing banning imports of
russian oil take that potent we're not
going to buy our gas from a war criminal
we're going to buy it from the good guys
saudi arabia
but
it's gonna cost
since the invasion oil prices have
skyrocketed today the average gas price
in america hit an all-time record high
of over four dollars per gallon okay
that stings but a clean conscience is
worth a buck or two
i'm willing to pay
it's important right
it's important i'm willing to pay four
dollars a gallon hell i'll pay 15
a gallon because i drive a tesla
right now ah nothing like an elitist
millionaire making fun of people who
actually are affected when they have to
pay more uh you look
i i do pretty well i do all right uh i
have a tesla or i'm i'm getting a new
tesla supposedly it's coming this week
um i love the tesla so i'm not i'm not
against green energy obviously i'm not
against electric i'm certainly for
nuclear all of these things but this
smug dismissal
of of the average person who has to
drive to work and a couple bucks a day
actually does mean something these
people are just absolutely gross and ah
but you'll have a clean conscience and
all the seals applaud oh we have a clean
conscience now uh guys we've known
putin's a bad dude for quite some time
so did you have a clean conscience two
weeks ago when we were buying oil from
him is your conscience clean then and he
even made the point
you actually almost did it you almost
made like a clear point there colbert
yes we're gonna now buy oil from saudi
arabia more oil from saudi arabia and
maybe go to venezuela et cetera et
cetera so will your conscience be clean
then
god these people are ridiculous but not
as ridiculous as msnbc's joy read
because you're not going to believe this
guys for her this is about
racism
now what we're seeing in ukraine is
absolutely the worst humanitarian crisis
that europe has seen in decades
but we haven't witnessed the same type
of solidarity for the yemenis
as we do for the ukrainians we don't see
historic sanctions or global campaigns
corporations like airbnb and netflix
taking a stand and this is not to say
that we shouldn't care this much for
ukraine far from it
the point is we should also care this
much for refugees and those facing
occupation and war in the middle east
and asia and africa too
the coverage of ukraine has revealed a
pretty radical disparity in how human
ukrainians look and feel to western
media compared to their browner and
blacker counterparts
i just don't even know what to do with
these people anymore like it is so sad
and depressing if at the end of the day
every which way you can see the world is
through the the very very narrow prism
of racism if that's really all you can
do then then your world is small and
myopic and sad and leads you to becoming
sort of bananas as joy reid actually is
i would love i said to my guys as we
were playing the clip just now i would
love to know how many times joy reid has
covered what's going on in yemen on her
show has she been leading has she once
led her show with what's going on in
yemen no of course i'm going to go out
on a limb and assume that no she hasn't
but please prove me wrong i'll gladly
correct myself tomorrow um
it is what it is these people are nuts
um i know this has been a bit of a heavy
show gas prices going up you know what's
going on the people in charge seem to be
lying to us they have media people that
run cover for them uh so i thought we
could end with some hope right because
we need hope we need hope everyone needs
hope in these in these troubling times
um and there's a woman
who is just she's just smart and she's
good and knowledgeable and forthright
and i think can help us in the future
her name's kamala harris and everything
i just said there was a lie we're
screwed people take a look at this
imagine a future
the freight trucks that deliver bread
and milk to our grocery store shelves
and the buses that take children to
school and parents to work imagine all
the heavy-duty vehicles that keep our
supply lines strong and allow our
economy to grow imagine
that they produced zero emissions
well you all imagined it
that's why we're here today
because we have the ability to see what
can be
unburdened by what has been
and then to make the possible
actually happen
imagine people
there was a world that was made of
marshmallows and there were rainbows
that connected one marshmallow to
another marshmallow and those
marshmallows could combine and become a
bigger marshmallow and it's you people
who support marshmallows who allow us to
have two marshmallows connected by a
rainbow and smiles and happiness it's
all very wonderful
she's a heartbeat away from the
presidency she's a heartbeat away from
the presidency i would not trust that
woman to teach third graders
basic math
not that they're allowed to teach basic
math anymore but i just wouldn't allow
it anyway
a couple comments from the reuben
report.locals.com community anya says
kamala went to poland end of war
everyone we are saved yes so supposedly
she's in poland right now is that right
they've sent her that's what i'm hearing
they've sent that
person
to solve the she does not know anything
about anything i could literally send my
dog i could send clyde we could ship him
over there i could drop him in the in
poland i could put him in the middle of
ukraine i could send him over to the
kremlin to talk with putin it would make
more sense than sending kamala harris
the woman is an idiot
rob says
honestly short of launching nukes i
cannot think of one thing this idiot
biden could do worse to destroy america
i agree and that's why i'm saying
if their plan is to destroy america then
you got to give the devil his due and
they're doing it quite well could they
possibly be this inept could everything
that they have done since joe biden has
come into office
been so accidentally horrible or could
this be exactly what they want and and
to me it seems to be the latter like
they want us off fossil fuels they want
the green new energy deal and aoc
occasional cortez's uh they want her
policies or whatever it all is you guys
get it and they're just
let no crisis go to waste right guys
we're moving past cobit we got the war
why not rejigger the world economy and
how we make energy and get energy and
all of our international relations
remember three weeks after kovid when i
was screaming the world's never coming
back and we better start thinking about
it does that kind of seem right right
now like it ain't coming back people but
by the way
to actually
uh leave on on a positive note there are
places
on this earth i happen to be in one of
them the great state of florida where
people are doing it right and are going
to do everything they can to fight this
and never forget that david b goliath so
as as bad as these people seem as big as
they seem big tech the companies the
banks all the stuff
it's like we always have a chance and
and the hu the long arc of human history
shows that people actually do beat the
bad guys but but these are not the good
guys that are in charge right now i'm
sorry they're just not uh all right guys
i gotta get out of here because i have
the final three chapters of dumper in
this country to record the audiobook for
maybe i'll do a little video from there
so you can sort of see what it's like in
the booth it's actually kind of cool you
get in there with booth there's a sound
engineer i got a guy in new york who's
listening making sure i pronounce every
single name right pause right on the
jokes all that stuff it's a really fun
process actually and oddly my my voice
seems pretty okay but yes you can
pre-order don't burn this country at
daverubin.combook and we have all the
links there where you can get the book
at amazon or barnes noble or your local
bookstore etc etc if you want to play
along during the show you can go to
rubyreport.locals.com and sign up
absolutely free part one of my interview
with former u.s ambassador to the u.n
nikki haley is up right now on youtube
and rumble and absolutely ad free at
locals
and that's it i'm just gonna uh here you
know what we'll do we'll do a an ending
where i uh put on my glasses here okay
so i'm a news man i put on my glasses
it's the end of the show and i'm just
gonna like pretend i'm reading and when
you feel it's time to go out connor
you'll just take us out but i'm reading
the stuff and reading